good morning everyone what i want to do
is share with you the three things that
will have the biggest direct
impact on how much money you make
[Music]
and so these are the three biggest
levers for growth in a business
three big levers
for biz growth all right
going up all right the first is gonna be
your market
all right and so the reason that uh
investors look at this stuff is because
they know
that if you put a great entrepreneur in
a bad market or a bad market
or a a bad entrepreneur in a great
market
the market will usually win and so let
me tell you a quick story about this to
illustrate this point
so uh one of my friends uh lloyd owned a
uh a great tech company he started it
probably a decade ago
and they grew pretty quickly and then it
sort of plateaued and then it started to
go down and
he was trying to figure this out and he
was struggling with it and he called me
up one and he was like hey dude
what do you think the issue is with this
and i was like dude you're you're
selling
your software to newspapers because that
was his exclusive customer
for his his ad product and despite
having an amazing offer
and being a great salesman uh because it
was a zero risk offer for them he only
just rev shared with them
despite both of those things he was not
able to grow
because he was in the newspaper market
which was shrinking by 25
every single year over eight years that
he had the business right he still
has it to the side but for eight years
she was trying to figure out what was
going on and he looked at every single
piece of the business except for
probably the most obvious one
which is the market itself and so what i
want to introduce you with these three
that levers and that's the first one is
the market
is you have to do these from the top
down all right if you're in a horrible
market it doesn't matter how good your
offer is it doesn't matter how good
your persuasive abilities are you prob
you will not be able to outpower a bad
market and so the way i look at these
levers is is this going to be a
plus is it going to be uh you know a
neutral or is it going to be a negative
right and so as long as your market is
not a negative
and is either neutral or a plus you can
move on to the second lever
for business growth all right the second
lever
is your offer all right and what i mean
by that
is what you're literally giving a
customer in order to transact with them
all right this is the the the products
and services that you offer in exchange
for money
and and the terms under which you offer
them and what they need to do
to redeem them all right that is in
essence what an offer is
all right and so these are the terms the
price etc
and what they get now if you're in a
normal market
or a good market if you're in a good
market it doesn't matter right uh if you
were
you know selling toilet paper during
covet it didn't matter
uh what uh what your offer was or how
persuasive you were which is the third
one
uh you were just you were in the right
market at the right time and you're
gonna make a ton of money
right but most of us are in this market
most of us are just in normal markets
that are growing
a normal amount and the nice thing is if
you're in one of those markets you can
still make a tremendous amount of money
by offering a unique offering and a good
product right
and so the offer is going to be the
second thing now if you have an
incredible
irresistible offer then more people will
say yes
and you can make a tremendous amount of
money but again here
you can have an amazing offer you can
have a normal offer or you can have a
shitty offer
right and as long as you do not have a
a shitty offer or a normal offer you can
move on to the next one all right which
is the third
big lever all right which is persuasion
all right
so some people are naturally good
persuaders they're good
um they're good marketers they're good
sales people
and the thing is is that each of these
is more important than
uh the rest all right so it goes from
the top down
so i'll give you some examples if i were
in
an amazing market it doesn't matter if
my offer persuasion abilities are good
i'll make a ton of money
if i'm in a bad market it doesn't matter
if i'm in a good persuasion and good
offering
i'm not going to make any money and so
basically you can just move from the top
down and check these off your list and
so most of us
are going to be here in this normal
market right a normal market you serve
dentists you serve chiropractors you
serve normal people who are in pain
those are normal markets they're not
growing they're not shrinking they're
just
normal right now from there we move to
our offer
now the thing is is that this is
typically the easiest lever on any
business
to grow the business because any
business it takes a little bit of time
to go from a normal offer to an amazing
offer you can't really go from a normal
market to an amazing market with your
business unless you change your entire
business
but with an offer you simply can
repackage the value proposition
how you charge in the terms under which
you offer your services
and you can move from having a normal
offering or a
subpar offering to an amazing
irresistible offer
i call them grand slam offers and the
reason i call them that is because grand
slams are both very rare and very good
but the difference between baseball and
business is that when you have a grand
slam offer
you can knock the ball so far out of the
park you can win for a thousand years
and that's the difference right in
baseball you can only win four runs no
matter how good your offer is
in business you're going in for life and
so
making the actual best offer is going to
be the second biggest lever
on your business now let's assume that
you've got a great offer
now if you have crap persuasion skills
you'll still make money
if you have normal persuasion stills
you'll make a lot of money if you have
fantastic persuasion skills you'll make
a tremendous amount of money
alright which leads me to the next piece
so let's assume that you just have a
normal offer not an amazing offer
all right then it takes us to our third
portion here the only way
if that is your scenario you're in a
normal market you're normal you have a
normal offer
the only way for you to be hyper
successful
is to develop persuasion abilities and
so that's learning how to market and
sell how to acquire customers
through multiple channels right and so
the thing is is that this one is usually
the most difficult to acquire in my
opinion it takes a lot of time takes a
lot of effort takes a lot of volume took
a lot of practice a lot of failure
in order to get good at this all right
and so if i'm looking at a business
and i'm trying to grow it the first
thing i'm going to do is check this off
is just say like are we making sure that
we're not in a bad market
and we're at least in a normal or good
market you'll know if you're in a good
market believe me like i said if you're
selling toilet paper cover 19
if you're selling hot dogs outside of a
baseball stadium as soon as the game
lets out you know you're in a good
market
right but most of us are here so as long
as i'm not in a bad market i move on to
the next one
and so if i'm looking at the business i
say okay what is the current offering
what are we doing in exchange for money
what are we giving clients right what
are the terms of the agreement what's
the price point and what are they
getting in exchange
all right and so then what i will do is
shift
the business from here in this direction
to create a grand slam offer and the
beautiful thing is this can literally
take a half a day
maybe a day right where you just re
recombine
repackage reposition rename the offers
change the terms under which you
you make you you offer your businesses
and services and products
and overnight you can take a normal
business to an extraordinary business
by doing this one thing all right and
then finally
the last thing that you can do is you
can develop all the skills of persuasion
so if you're looking at the
entrepreneurial journey
my recommendation for most people is i
start here this is the first thing i
will do
the second thing i will do is get them
to focus here and on improving this
skill
and going from a normal sales person to
a normal marketer to an exceptional
salesperson marketer
because they should already be being
reasonably successful because we fixed
the offer first
and then move up to the top the biggest
lever and say now that we understand how
to make amazing offers
how to persuade people in masses now
let's go find a market that we know we
can apply the skill set to that we think
is going to
crush it so right now if your business
is not growing
it might be because you are lacking one
two or all three of the levers
that create success um and so if that
hopefully that found it you you found
that valuable hopefully you can think
about your own business within this
context
am i in a a great market a normal market
or a shrinking market
is my offer insanely compelling is it
normal or is it bad
my are my persuasion abilities
exceptional can i acquire
clients at the snap of my fingers
whenever i want do they come in
kind of semi-consistently but you know i
can't really grow it
or do i have no idea what i'm doing and
i get i get people on the phone and i
can never get money
right and so if you can rate yourself on
these things then you can identify where
you have opportunities for growth
and then follow these steps to get to
where you want to go
so hopefully that you found value in
that hopefully that was cool in terms of
in terms of framing how growth and the
biggest levers that exist in business
overall
uh and keeping awesome and i will uh
see you on the flip side bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you